[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Joining us now are
developer advocates Rachael
Tatman and Sara Robinson
to set the stage for what's
in store during the
developer keynote.
Welcome.
Rachael, please kick us
off by describing Kaggle.
RACHAEL TATMAN: Sure, Kaggle
is the home of data science.
So you might know us for our
supervised Machine Learning
competitions.
And we still do that,
but right now, we
have a lot more on the site.
So we've got public data
sets that anyone can use.
If you want to
analyze your own data,
you can upload it
privately, not share it out.
And we also have a hosted
Jupiter development
environment.
So that includes
GPU acceleration
offered at no
charge, and we just
upgraded from K80s to P100s.
So if you're looking for
a little bit of zhuzh
in your algorithm
run speed, it can
be a nice little added bonus.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
And how are data
scientists and analysts
utilizing Kaggle to support
their Machine Learning
projects?
RACHAEL TATMAN: Yeah, a
lot of different ways.
So the thing I think
that's probably
most unique about
Kaggle is we have
a really big community, about
2.7 million registered users.
And we have a
super active forum.
So it can be really
hard to find information
about your specific questions,
especially Machine Learning
and AI.
And things are
moving so quickly.
So having a community that you
can go to, and ask questions,
and learn together is a
really fantastic resource.
STEPHANIE WONG: And Sara, have
you used Kaggle in your work
and seen its benefits
in the ML community?
SARA ROBINSON: Yes, I use
Kaggle almost every day.
I'm always looking for
interesting data sets
for Machine Learning demos.
And Kaggle is my go-to for that.
You can find almost
any type of data
set you're looking for--
images, text, structured data
on Kaggle.
So it's been a
great tool for me.
RETO MEIER: That's fantastic.
What ML AI launches are
you most excited about?
And tell me a little
bit about why.
SARA ROBINSON: There's
some AutoML launches
that I'm super excited
about, really making
it easy for anyone to use
Machine Learning without having
to have Machine
Learning expertise.
So the first I'll talk
about is AutoML tables,
which makes it really easy to
build custom machine learning
models on structured data.
So think about
anything you might
be able to put in a
spreadsheet, categorical data,
numerical data,
building models on that.
With AutoML tables,
that's really easy.
Upload your data to the UI.
Press a Train button, and
your model's ready to go.
Another AutoML launch
I'm super excited about
is AutoML Vision
Object Detection.
So AutoML Vision can
already do classification,
but now what you'll
be able to do
is identify regions
in your image, where
a certain label exists.
So it will return
bounding boxes.
So I'm super excited about
those AutoML launches.
RETO MEIER: Very cool.
And we're about to see
a showcase highlighting
our work with the NCAA
using BigQuery ML.
What can you tell us about
BigQuery ML specifically?
SARA ROBINSON: BQML lets
folks that have structured
data stored in BigQuery--
BigQuery is our cloud
data analytics warehouse.
So it lets you create
Machine Learning models on
that data stored in BigQuery,
just with a single SQL query.
So you don't have to move your
data out of BigQuery to use it.
It's super simple to use.
So you just write a query.
Your models train, and then
you can write another query
to generate a prediction.
I actually gave
a session on BQML
earlier today with
one of our customers,
AAA, that's using BQML
to predict call volumes
across their call centers.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
And Rachael, have you also heard
about BQML in the launch, too?
RACHAEL TATMAN:
Yeah, definitely.
And I checked out
that NCAA showcase.
One thing that I
found really exciting
was student developers
were working
on developing new features for
analyzing basketball games.
So one of them was clutchness,
like how many points
you're going to score in
the last five minutes.
And I thought that
was super interesting
because on Kaggle, we've
hosted NCAA competitions where
you predict the winning team.
And I think it was a
couple of years ago,
one of the very high
placers had just
used linear regression, which
is available in BigQuery ML.
Let me say all the
words correctly.
And also these custom
features that they developed.
So I'm seeing some
interesting synergy there.
STEPHANIE WONG: This
is the perfect time
to check in with our
colleague Joanna Smith, who,
earlier, had a chance to stop
by our NCAA showcase demo.
JOANNA SMITH: I'm Joanna.
And I'm here in the Industry
Solutions neighborhood
of our expo floor, looking
at this great energy.
All these people
are really excited.
And I'm standing
with Alok, who's
going to show us the NCAA demo.
You want to take it away?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah, so
this is our second year
at Google Cloud being
the official Cloud
provider of the NCAA.
Our theme is know
what your data knows.
So we've been working with the
actual NCAA basketball data
to make a lot of
insights and predictions.
So let's look at one.
We just had our national title
game, Virginia and Texas Tech.
And what we're
looking at here is
the number of possessions each
team will have in regulation.
So we predicted that the
number will be 63 or fewer.
And it was 59 in regulation.
So it was right.
JOANNA SMITH: Not bad.
ALOK PATTANI: But we've
done a bunch more.
So one of the
other things we did
was we looked at a
Data Studio dashboard.
So Data Studio, another
tool made by Google,
allows you to
visualize your data.
We had developed a bunch
of different metrics
for all these teams in NCAA.
You can see them on
the bottom here--
score control, clutchness,
discipline, et cetera.
But we wanted to surface
that data in a way
that people could
use, filter, and sort.
So this has all the 353 teams.
But if we just want to
look at the champion,
we can go here and
select champion only.
JOANNA SMITH: Should
have been Tech.
ALOK PATTANI: And
boom, Virginia.
And now we can see
where they rank in all
the different categories.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, I like it.
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Is that a
good score for clutchness?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
So the ranks are right there.
So you can tell, it's
seventh out of 353 teams.
JOANNA SMITH: Not bad.
ALOK PATTANI:
That's pretty good.
They're third in score control.
They're a deserving champion.
JOANNA SMITH: So
you said this is
Data Studio, which we
know is for visualization,
which is really cool.
But you mentioned
other Cloud tools.
I think BigQuery played
a big part in this.
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Can you
show me how that worked?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah, so the
first thing we had to do
is make a pipeline
to ingest the data.
So this is a small
screen here, but I'll
show you this is on
our Google Cloud blog.
We describe the entire pipeline
of how we built this data.
And you can see there's
a bunch of stuff,
and then we get to BigQuery
right in the middle.
And I'm a data scientist.
I want stuff in BigQuery
because then I can go and do
all my stuff, right?
So BigQuery, let's do it.
And then what we do from
there is, we take the data,
we do a lot of
manipulations, and to build
that metric, like
score control, we
have to write a bunch of code.
JOANNA SMITH: All right,
so you got the cloud blog.
And then you also post
it on Medium, right?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Some
more fun insights?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
So on Medium what we did was,
we wanted to talk more in depth
about how we built this metric.
So one, we wanted to
describe in detail
for the technical people, but
also talk about the basketball
context.
So you have this thing, how
the final score can lie,
score control, right?
And in here we go through
a couple example games
where teams control
the score differently.
But then again, we
get back to BigQuery.
JOANNA SMITH: I love it.
ALOK PATTANI: So
here is a long query.
And again, it looks fairly
complicated, and it kind of is.
But it actually
is when you think
about how you go about
doing this calculation,
BigQuery makes it pretty
easy with these aggregation
functions, and it
runs really fast.
JOANNA SMITH: And it may be
long, but it's easy to read.
ALOK PATTANI: And
it runs really fast.
Gets us our results for
all thousands of games
in a matter of seconds.
And then we can move
forward and do other stuff.
JOANNA SMITH: Love scale power.
Now you have one more
thing in this blog, right,
at the bottom?
I was playing with your, what
was it, an interactive scatter
plot?
ALOK PATTANI: Yes, so if we
keep going here, eventually we
get to a point where we see
this scatter plot, which
plots all 353 teams
in their school colors
and shows their
difference between--
JOANNA SMITH: School colors.
ALOK PATTANI: --the score
control and a different metric.
JOANNA SMITH: I like it.
So if anyone wants to
kind of find that at home,
they can search NCAA on our
Cloud blog or they can look--
we're cross-linked.
This is a Cloud publication.
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
g.co/marchmadness.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, nice.
ALOK PATTANI: I know it's
a little bit past March,
but the tournament is
still fresh in my mind.
So it should be fun to look at.
JOANNA SMITH: Well, thank you
so much for talking to me.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow,
amazing showcase.
How is BigQuery ML
changing the game
for machine learning for
developers and practitioners?
RACHAEL TATMAN:
Yeah, good question.
Two things that
come to mind for me.
First of all, being
able to work in SQL.
So something we found
in our Kaggle machine
learning developer survey
is that SQL's actually
the third most commonly used
language for machine learning.
And also people who are
outside of the machine
learning AI space who are just
coming into it, many of them
are already familiar with SQL.
So being able to use tools that
you already know how to use
is a really big time saver.
And also, you don't have
to download data locally.
So if you've got sensitive data
that you can't store locally
or it's just like really big
and you can't store it on disk,
being able to do your
regression in BigQuery instead
of having to
download everything,
do your Python code and
then upload everything
once you've changed your model,
that can be a big time saver.
SARA ROBINSON: And
to add to that,
I think BQML is a great entry
point for machine learning.
So you don't have to worry
about any sort of feature
engineering.
So if you have categorical
data, for example,
if you're building
a model yourself,
you would have to one hot
encode that into arrays.
BQML can recognize that
it's a categorical column
and transform your data for you.
RETO MEIER: That's excellent.
Democratization of data has
been a big theme at Google.
We really believe that
if you want innovation,
you have to democratize
access to data.
Can you talk a little about
how BigQuery ML and AutoML
are having an impact
towards us being
able to achieve that goal?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, definitely.
So both BQML and AutoML make
it easy for anyone, regardless
of your machine
learning expertise,
to build your own custom
machine learning model.
So you don't need a lot of
machine learning expertise
to get started.
You just upload
your data, choose
the type of model you
want, and both BQML AutoML
will handle the rest.
RACHAEL TATMAN: And
AutoML specifically, you
don't need as much
labeled data as well.
So I know the natural
language API, sorry,
the natural language
AutoML that just launched,
you only need 100 label
examples per category
for each label in your
categorical learning
example, which is very little
data, especially when you're
looking at like a BERT or ELMo,
these really, really enormous
GPT2, enormous language models.
So being able to get started
with relatively little data,
smaller time investment, smaller
money investment for labeling
is a really big movement
towards democratization.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
Sara, you'll actually be
talking about the path
from Cloud AutoML to custom
model in your breakout session.
Can you give us a preview
of the key factors
when moving from AutoML
into custom ML models?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, definitely.
So the goal of our
breakout session tomorrow--
I'm going to be
speaking with Yu Fang--
is to teach people that may
not have built their own custom
model before, how
to get started.
Because at least
for me, the process
of starting to learn how
to build a custom model
is really intimidating.
There's lots of
resources out there.
It's hard to know
where to get started.
So we're going to break it
down, talk about feature
transformations,
feature engineering
that you need to do to go
from AutoML to custom model,
and walk through some code.
And there'll also be a
couple of live demos.
RETO MEIER: Rachael, you'll also
be leading a session tomorrow,
using Google's data and AI
technologies with Kaggle.
What sort of things
will you cover?
And what part of it are
you most excited about?
RACHAEL TATMAN: Ooh.
So we are going to give people
a little tour of Kaggle,
because a lot of things
have changed recently.
And then we're also going to
talk about several integrations
that we've made recently.
And honestly, the one that
I'm most excited about
is the ability to take
Kaggle data set and launch it
as a Sheets instance,
a Google Sheets
instance with a single
click of a button.
And one place where I
think this could actually
be extremely useful for people,
is for project management.
So you're writing a
kernel, a notebook,
and you're generating, let's
say, your hyper parameter
search space.
You save that as a data set,
you launch it as a sheet,
and then you can assign action
items, link to other kernels,
use [? tracks, ?] use color
coding, which you wouldn't want
to do in a CSV, but
can be really super
useful for project management.
So I'm very excited
about that integration.
RETO MEIER: Very cool.
STEPHANIE WONG: Excellent.
Thank you so much,
Rachael and Sara.
SARA ROBINSON:
Thanks for having us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]